Learner B1: العبور.
Learner B3: الحمد لله الأخبار.
Learner B1: الحمد لله.
Learner B3: طيب إنتو وصلتوا لإيه.
Learner B1: اخر حاجة اتفقنا عليها ان هو المفروض الفرن خلاص يعني
Learner B1: يعني مبارح ندعم ضبطيها وخلاص كانت المفروض تنزل يعني بس ما اعرفش اللي حصل
Learner B1: ما تبعدش يعني مع ندى و
Learner B1: تمام يعني الدنيا ماشية مفيش حاجة يعني.
Learner B3: تمام هو كان قالها ل ألعاب سيكل يعني طويلة وكذا وأنه ممكن أنزلها بس لو أسود
Learner B3: فأنا حاسة أنه ما فيش خلاص وقت الأسبوع ده.
Learner B1: والله نزلت وجات عليها ما نزلتش خلاص إمم إحنا عملنا وسط.
Learner B3: ممكن.
Learner B1: أم فين الباقي مدني سندوت.
Learner B3: من.
Learner B1: هي أونلاين سكة.
Learner B3: أم.
Learner B1: زوينة
Learner B1: يسر
Learner B1: هل تدلني
Learner B1: ياسر؟
Learner B1: هو مش فاتح أون لاين وعملتله منشن.
Learner B1: ما أعرفش ردة فعل.
Learner B4: مريم عادل راوان وزينب منين
Learner B1: الحمد الله.
Learner B4: الحمد لله زي الفل اللي فات.
Learner B7: شكرا جدا على السؤال يا ندى. شكرا.
Learner B4: إمم
Learner B4: طب قولوا لنا الأخبار.
Learner B7: أنا بس عايز أسأل سؤال أكيد.
Learner B4: الربيع.
Learner B7: لحم روني ونصف بصراحة أنا تعبت جدا اليومين اللي فاتوا جدا يعني
Learner B7: وحسيت إن إحنا عملناها وكمان ماركت ريزرج حاصل ما هو
Learner B7: بعيد شوية عن مشكلة التذكر الأساسية، فممكن حد يوضحلنا صح ولا لأ.
Learner B1: بصي بصي معلش هو الفكرة إعتبري الفورم والأسئلة دي
Learner B1: حاجة كده ملهاش علاقة والله جات تمام ما جاتش بس عادي يعني.
Learner B7: أيوة عشان خاطر البشمندس أحمد اللي بيدخل معانا حاجات تانية يعني فين ماركت فين
Learner B7: فين الداتا في مبدأ يسأل عن حاجات بحس منه. إن إحنا يا إننا يعني بحس إن أنا بعيدة شوية عن الموضوع.
Learner B1: لحد معين لو يقدر يجاوبنا على.
Learner B1: الترنت تيم ممكن يفتح ويجاوبنا لو عندنا أسئلة ولا لدي أيها.
Learner B7: هو إي آي تقريبا بياخد التان دانس بس.
Learner B1: منو.
Learner B4: طيب قلي أسألتك عاد.
Learner B1: لا يعني هو لو أنا تفكيري صح أو غلط اللي هو فكرة إن إحنا نشتغل على التوست دي عادي خالص
Learner B1: والفورم جات جتود بتاعتها أوكي ما جاتلناش خلاص عادي صح؟ أنا كده ولا.
Learner B4: بالظبط انت ما عندكش يعني انت ما عندكش حلول تانية يعني انت محتاج ومحتاج لو عرفت تسأل حد من زمن
Learner B4: الثانية. إسألهم تواصل معاهم أعرف منهم. القصة دي. ومع الماركة وصلت لنا إينسايت وصلتين ما وصلتيناش حنحتاجها في ال سبرينت الجاي.
Learner B1: مزلو.
Learner B7: دلوقتي عملتي بروتو تايب قبل ما إحنا نفكر في الفورم كدا
Learner B7: له علاقة له علاقة بس مركز على الحتة دي أكتر. فبعد ال فورم وكده بقيت حاسة إنه لأ في شغل بجانب تاني أكتر وإن أنا يعني ال يبقى ناقص أو بعيد شوية عن اللي إنتو بتعملوه كمان مختلفين عني مش عارفة ليه
Learner B7: عشان كده.
Learner B4: أو.
Learner B7: انتو شغالين على المشكلة المبعوتة على سيركل وكمان على بس.
Learner B4: هو البشوانس آخر مرة قال إن إنتو الأمر مش بس فيدباك إنتو المشكلة شاملة كل حاجة.
Learner B7: أيوة.
Learner B4: يعني.
Learner B7: يعني أفكر.
Learner B4: كله.
Learner B7: يعني أفكر إن هم عندهم حماسهم بيقل ليه أصلا يعني ما فكرش إن هو عشان خاطر في ضغط على.
Learner B4: حماس هو تكلم على نقطة إن إنت بالظبط قال كده تحسيني إزاي.
Learner B7: بس إذا ده طازكي مختلف تماما. ده أنا فهمتو
Learner B7: فبقيت حاسه ان انا يعني في حتة تانية.
Learner B4: عارفة.
Learner B7: على.
Learner B4: وصلت منقوصة ومش دي طاس اللي هو كان قاصدها بس خلينا نور كل ده وخلينا نتعامل إن دي
Learner B4: إحنا عايزين نحسن من انتيرناشون كله.
Learner B7: انت بس يعني دلوقتي أقعد أركز يعني دلوقتي ممكن أعمل على نفسي صح؟
Learner B4: عن نفسك وعلى زمانك لكل التراكتر الموجودة.
Learner B7: أيوا أنا فاهمة أنا فاهمة. أقصد أقول إن أنا دلوقتي مش محتاجة بقى يعني إننا أركز على مشكلة من أبعاد مختلفة. أو إن أنا إذا إحنا مش محتاجين مركز برا.
Learner B4: انت محتاجة عشان خاطر لو انت عايزة تعرفي إينسايد اللي هي لسه مش عندك.
Learner B7: طب ممكن أعرف أنا أحتاج ماركت فورم التانية ليه
Learner B7: لأنهم هدفهم إن هم يطلعوا بتحسين ليه انتر بتاع سبرينس بس.
Learner B1: يعني اللي زيك في السوق بيقدموا إي مثلا شغالين زي أحسن منك اللي غلطتهم عشان تستفيدي منهم.
Learner B4: هو المرة اللي فاتت الريد أوشن و بلو أوشن في الحتة. دي مظبوط يا عادل.
Learner B1: مظبوط.
Learner B7: تمام دي الوقت مختلف يعني زي ما أنا فهمت مختلف.
Learner B1: بصي حتة الفورم دي يعني اعتبريها حاجة زيادة ماشي الفورم.
Learner B7: لا هي الفورمة حاجة عادية. أنا شايفاها جزء من ال بروسيس عادي خالص.
Learner B1: الفورم والجو التاسك اللي موجود غلط دي يعني إحنا من الآخر السكوب بقى أوسع مشي بس إحنا.
Learner B1: خلينا ملتزمين بالليت تمام ده اللي هو التوسك المبعوت لنا بس.
Learner B4: مظبوط.
Learner B7: تمام لكن طب ماشي لما يدخل معانا بلانك ده الأسبوع الجاي بيناقشنا بحاجات مختلفة يعني ساعتها أكون محضرة
Learner B1: حقولك على حاجة أنت عادي. وحضري. توست عادي تمام
Learner B1: لو فيدباك يعني فورم ما نزلتش والردود بتاعت الناس ما جتلناش خلاص إحنا نشتغل أنا عملت كذا وكذا وكذا في في البرينت بتاعي طب اللي اتفقنا عليه كان فين طب هو فين ردود ناس فين الحاجات بس.
Learner B4: في.
Learner B7: وأكد إن إحنا نعمل ماركت ديس وما نوقفش وأكد على دفع ميساج على على.
Learner B1: عادي إعمليها يعني كانت مطلوبة يعني أنا كنت.
Learner B7: أم.
Learner B1: إيه.
Learner B7: إنه من بعيد أوي إنه من بعيد يعني دلوقتي مطلوب مني أطلع أصلا حاجة بقى شبه أساسي يعني الحتة دي قديمة شوية
Learner B7: فدلوقتي حاسه ان انا فعلا بصورة طسكي مختلف.
Learner B3: مسيو.
Learner B7: بس هو لما يدخل معانا وبيدينا فيدباك عننا وبيدينا فيدباك على اللي بيحصل وبحس منه إن إحنا أنا بحس منه إنه أنا سننا بعيدة يعني مش عارفة أنا أعيش قوي بالذات المرة اللي فاتت.
Learner B1: علشان نفس حتة. هو كان فاكر ان هو بعتك يعني مبعودة زي ما هو فاكر وهي تعمل بحاجة مختلفة. فهو كان بيتكلم بنقطة
Learner B1: مختلفة ولما قلتلوش لما شاف التذكرة راح فاهم بقى.
Learner B7: تمام يعني انتو متفقين معايا؟ في إنه في لخبطة. مش أنا أبقى مختلفة عنكو.
Learner B4: إنت حاولي إنت حاولي يا زينب إن إنت يعني تحلي أو تحطي نفسك كبرودة منجر لل انترنشون كلها تبذلي أقصى مجهود فيها
Learner B4: فقدرتي تحطي إيدك على كذا مشكلة تمام قدرتي تحطي إيدك على مشكلة واحدة تمام ماركة حيديكي إن سايتس
Learner B4: علشان تحطي أولوياتك أي مشكلة منهم اللي تشتغلي عليهم.
Learner B7: طيب أنا ما عنديش مشكلة بصراحة دلوقتي لو إن المشكلة إننا دلوقتي أحسن ال إنترنت في حاجة كلير يعني حاجة أنا أشتغل عليها خلاص
Learner B7: دلوقتي عادي جدا. أنا أكون مسلمة حاجة ليها علاقة بالحماس بس
Learner B7: وبتناقش معاكم في حاجة تانية ومع الباشنت أحمد لما يكون معانا في حاجة تانية.
Learner B4: إنت مش فكرة حماس الفكرة إن إنت ليه شفتي إن ده الأولوية إلى النقطة.
Learner B7: أيوة يعني قصدك إن كده ال بي ار دي اللي نازلة مفترضة مشكلة هي مفترضة حاجة وحدة.
Learner B4: إنت إنت الإفتراض أو المشكلة تقولي يعني أنا باجي أقول عندي مشكلة أنا بفلترهم ازاي بفلترهم عشان أنا استخدمت المتركس اللي هو كان قايل عليها اللي هي الرايس مثلا عشان أعمل بورترايز عشان أقول دي المشكلة الأساسية أو دي المشكلة الأكثر أهمية
Learner B4: أو دي. المشكلة. انها لو حليتها
Learner B4: ححل مشاكل كتير أو حتدي إيفيكت أعلى المثال بتاع ال كود بتاع ال أوتو بي
Learner B4: هي مشكله واحده صغيره اداها هو الأولوية بناء على المترك دي. وبناء عليه
Learner B4: او عملتله ريفليكشن عادي جدا فدي النقطة هل الحماس ده
Learner B4: دي المشكلة الأساسية أو من ضمن المشاكل المهمة في التدريب. دا السؤال.
Learner B7: 70.
Learner B3: بصي يا زينب ممكن أنا أقولك اللي أنا عملته في
Learner B3: اننا اشتغلت على الفيد باك اللي هو كان موجود في اللي هو كان بويت كده وكان في اللي هو وبعد كده عملت زي ما ندى قالت عملت الرايس
Learner B3: عملت ال مثل ما تشوفي
Learner B3: عشان تحددي أني حاجة فعلا فيها بيرتي
Learner B3: بيست فور ناو. أنا هكمل عادي على الفيد باك اللي تعمل وبرضه ممكن تعملي ماركت عشان تشوفي عامة إحنا مختلفين ازاي عن برا ولو عرفتي تسألي برضه ناس برضه جوا جوا نفسها
Learner B3: بس بدل لغاية دلوقتي. أنا حشتغل على الفيدباك إحنا ألريدي معانا حاجة ملموسة؟ بس أنا مش حفترض فاهمة.
Learner B7: أنا أنا فهمت ده إنه خلاص في في جانب ثاني أنا بشتغل عليه بشكل أوسع فكرة بس أنا بحس إن أنا لما بدخل معاي أي ميتينغ. بحس إنه هو بيتناقش في حاجة أوسع شوية
Learner B7: ودي تاني مرة تقريبا يتقال إن الطازك ناقص أو ملغبط أو كذا فده ده الحاجة كنت عايز. تأكدها لي عندنا بس ولا عندكوا إنتو كمان.
Learner B1: بصي هو يعني برضه إيه مش بيركز على حتة الطسك أد ما بيركز على حتة إنت فكرتي ازاي.
Learner B7: تمام.
Learner B1: يعني أنا دخلت دورت على كده وعملت كذا وعملت ماشي بتاعتك كانت عاملة بيركز أو بيفهمه غلط، فإنه يصحح.
Learner B7: ممكن سؤالي إنتو عندكو فكرة عن الديمودي ده حيكون عامل إزاي يعني كل التاسكات اللي سلمناها الفيلز اللي إحنا جهزناها دي حناخدها معانا كمشكلة كاملة على مراحل ولا هنبدأ بقى نناقش من غير الفايلس دي أصلا. يعني المناقشة هتكون في بالظبط
Learner B7: عندكوا فكرة.
Learner B4: لا ما عندناش فكره هو احنا لسه مفترض لما القراب يقولولنا.
Learner B7: تمام.
Learner B4: في حد هو بيعمل باسك فيه. أي حاجة واقفة معاه محتاج مساعدة محتاج سؤال.
Learner B7: عملت اللي هو البروتوتي تايب دا.
Learner B4: طيب كويس جدا. باقي الشباب الدنيا.
Learner B3: أنا لسه شغالة بس مش عارفة إذا كنت أصلا هالحق ولا لأ لو هندخل بكرة.
Learner B4: تسلمي بكرة.
Learner B3: هو أنا كده عادي بس كنت أقعد يعني أزود وأحسن الموضوع
Learner B3: فأنا مش عارفة هيبقى بكرة ولا لحد.
Learner B4: ميتين جليليتر.
Learner B3: مفروض الخميس بس إحنا إنتو خدتوها الأسبوع ده لحد صح؟
Learner B4: لأ هو الخميس إحنا كان في
Learner B4: لا الاسبوع ده كان حد كان.
Learner B3: بس إحنا عنا مع بعض.
Learner B4: هو الريترو علشان نحن دخلنا ريترو محدش جون بطل.
Learner B3: إحنا كمان أه.
Learner B4: هو بس دي الفكره مثل ما هو غدا الأسبوع قبل بداية الاسبوع الجاي.
Learner B1: الموجود في يعني الديمو دي في.
Learner B4: تتفقين.
Learner B1: كل شيء ما أعرف ما اعتقدش ان في حاجة حتكون مفيدة يعني هو
Learner B1: صورة لو هتعملي بريتنتيشن يعني لو أنا فاهم صح.
Learner B4: فرنش زي كده اعمل
Learner B4: طيب حد الشباب عنده إينسايت ولا نروح نكمل التسجيل قد كده ورانا.
Learner B1: أنا.
Learner B5: ثلاثية.
Learner B5: هو إحنا كده يعني مش شغالين على فكرة فيدباك بس
Learner B5: عشان كده كله دخل في بعضه عندي.
Learner B1: الفيدر بس.
Learner B5: بس تمام.
Learner B1: لغاية يعني اشتغلي على التذكرة مطلوب منك عادي اللي موجودة على إشتغلي عليها
Learner B1: لغاية بقى لما يكون في معانا أي حاجة جديدة غير كدا لا إحنا خلينا ماشيين بتاعتنا هيدي خبز.
Learner B5: يعني أكمل على سبرينتون وتوعي.
Learner B1: بالظبط يعني خالص لغاية زي ما احنا.
Learner B4: بالظبط لحد ما ترد على وكده عشان يقدر يكون عندنا إنفورميشن.
Learner B5: تمام ماشي شكرا.
Learner B1: برضه يعني في حاجة أنا نسيتها ما تنسوش تعملوا ما خدش بالي منها إيه الإبك وال يودر ستوري والحاجات دي بعملوها على بي إم تول تمام
Learner B1: أنا خترت دفيرة.
Learner B4: أيوة.
Learner B1: تريل.
Learner B4: ياجيرا يا جيرا يا تريلوا يا شباب وحدة منهم.
Learner B1: أنا دي خد بالي منها في الآخر بس هي يعني تذكر بسيطة مش معقدة.
Learner B3: وانتو ال هتسألوا يوزرز أو حاجة ولا.
Learner B1: بصي الحتة دي فيدباك وإحنا نسأل يوزر نخليها نخليها لما يجينا فيدباك حي
Learner B1: خلينا لما يجي لما لما يجي رد من فوق.
Learner B7: أظن المفروض عليها قوي يعني هو بعث مسج مخصوص أصلا على.
Learner B4: مؤكدا.
Learner B7: علبة المايك بيزر جدا.
Learner B4: أنا كنت حقول إن أنا قلت هو أكد على ماركت ريتشرش والليوزر إنترفيوز فأنا
Learner B4: انا كندا اللي حعملو ححاول أو حد من زمايلي في التانية وحاول
Learner B4: الغالبة ده حيكون بكرة ححاول أسمع منهم أي حاجة أي فيدباك كده.
Learner B3: طب هل نعمل فيدباك صغير قوي ونبعته مثلا لكم حد.
Learner B7: طب ليه يا جماعة ما نفترض إن إحنا لو جينا نعمل انترفيو مش هنقدر نمسك غير اتنين ونخنقهم ونثبتهم.
Learner B1: أن.
Learner B7: يعودوا معانا.
Learner B1: أميلي أميلي عملوا يلا.
Learner B7: بالضبط.
Learner B1: يظهر.
Learner B7: كنز يحمي.
Learner B1: أي حد.
Learner B3: والله حاسة ممكن.
Learner B1: يا جماعة مش التدريب يلا كل 1 والله يسأل أي حد.
Learner B7: يعني أصلها إحنا في الآخر مش هنقهر على 1 أو 2 بكتير قوي
Learner B7: يعني محدش حيرضى محدش هييجي محدش فاضي.
Learner B1: بصي هو لو يعني لو طالما هو دقق على حتة أنا عايز أقرأ كلامه ثاني عشان أتأكد.
Learner B4: فرنش.
Learner B1: من.
Learner B7: وأؤكد عليها كمان إن هو يكون ماركت ريز برا انترنت على ناس تانية يعني مش شرط يكون جوا سبرينت أصلا.
Learner B1: مش عارفها.
Learner B7: وأكد عليها انها تكون معمولة على برا جدا. ده أنا حسيته من ميساج قوي.
Learner B1: ماركت ده حرة
Learner B1: ممكن إنت مش ملتزمة بيه بأي حد مش مضطرة تسألي أي حاجة إنتي بس بتشوفي الكلام اللي كان موجود بتنقي مثلا بلاس فورم زي كورتينا مثلا بتخشي فيها وبتعبي فيها شوية تمام ده مش معقدة تمام.
Learner B3: تلفون ده.
Learner B1: إيه.
Learner B3: كورسيرا والحاجات. دي ممكن تبقى نقارنها بسبنس الفيديز اللي عليها بس مش الانترنت نفسها.
Learner B7: أيوة دي المشكلة بقى دي مشكلة حسيت إن أنا عملت على كورسات مش على.
Learner B3: بالظبط.
Learner B4: عشان كده في ماركة حتبحثي عندك في الماركة مين بكون بقدم حاجة مشابهة لده.
Learner B3: أنا حاولت أشوف عامة بس حاسة الموضوع ما فيش أوبشنز كتير قوي زي كورسيس العادية.
Learner B7: ممكن مثلا نفكر في شركة عادية خالص عملت أنت عادية نشرتكم متخصصة.
Learner B1: شنت قبل كده ثانية واحدة معلش أشوف التهاني عندي فين.
Learner B3: الفكرة يا زينب إن هو أنا حاسة إن ما تبقى مختلفة. ما هي دي مش حتبقى أو حاجة أو هايبرد ليست يعني.
Learner B7: ممكن نلاقي فين ممكن نلاقي في كرير وين لقيتي لو جرفوا المكان ده.
Learner B4: بالظبط.
Learner B7: أتوقع عندهم اتوقع.
Learner B4: موظف.
Learner B7: كده بتبدأي تدخلي الجرني كده حوالي 4 أسابيع التراك معين مثلا.
Learner B3: أم.
Learner B4: في عندك في تقريبا ساعات بيعملوا تراكس زي كده.
Learner B7: أيوة.
Learner B4: عندك.
Learner B7: كان ممكن مثلا سوريا جدا.
Learner B4: لا.
Learner B7: هل ممكن مثلا. نفكر في أكتيڤيتي أو حاجة تطوعية بتقدم
Learner B7: حاجة يعني بس يكون حاجة كبيرة طبعا لأن هم لازم يكونوا بيشتغلوا على مشاريع أو بيدوا كورسات وكذا إحنا عايزين نختار مثلا أكتيڤيتي أو حتى حاجة تطوعية بس تكون كبيرة يعني مش سانت أكتيڤيتي عادي أو بسيط.
Learner B3: المحاسبة تبقى مختلفة أوي يعني مختلف.
Learner B7: تمام.
Learner B4: بالظبط.
Learner B3: من.
Learner B4: يعني حاولي حاولي دايما وأنت بتكري زينب خلي قدامك الحاجة
Learner B4: ليها يعني أنا مثلا حدور على الشركة. أنا بدور في أي مجال. أنا بدور في كورسات بس أنا بدور لا شركة تكون كورسات
Learner B4: وتكون في نفس الوقت بتقدم مثلا ما تسوقش فتخشي في التطوع وتخش في حاجات كتيرة مختلفة.
Learner B1: معلش حاطعك كلامك يا ندى. ممكن تقليلوا السكوب كمان إن إنتو مش بدوروا على بس لا إنتو بدوروا على إي آي بيدي فيدباك
Learner B1: وده موجود في كورسيرا يعني أنا ثانية واحدة حجيبهولكم.
Learner B7: يا بصراحة فكرة كويسة بس أنا حاسة إن ممكن يكون من ضمن التحسينات اللي حنعملها أصلا إن إحنا ما يكنش هو اللي بيدي فيدباك.
Learner B4: عندك حاجة ثانية؟ إسمها الإكس دول برضو بيعملوا حاجة قريبة من اللي احنا فيه ده وانت عارفينها.
Learner B7: ايوه عارفينهم دوكا.
Learner B1: دكتور.
Learner B7: كويس من برا.
Learner B1: ده اللي نقصده علشان بس يعني إنتو يعني جايين تكون فكرة إن إحنا نعمل كلها ماشي تنفع لما يكون في بنك بتاع مجالنا
Learner B1: أما دلوقتي برضه معرفش يعني اللي أنا اشتغلت عليه قبل كده كان اللي هو فكرة اللي عندها نفس المشكلة إن في بنك بيوصل متأخر من اي
Learner B1: أو عندها فكرة الإي آي في بيك.
Learner B7: طب ليه مثلا ما يكنش أصلا المشكلة إحنا دلوقتي مشتغل على تحسين ككل
Learner B7: ليه ما نفكرش إن أصلا حاجة مش كويسة أصلا.
Learner B7: ليه ما يكونش في منتور هيومن لي.
Learner B1: في.
Learner B7: دي ما فكرتش إن ده من ضمن التحسينات. اصلا واحنا عايزين عادي نفكر يعني مش شرط إيه.
Learner B1: إنت كده بتكلميه كدينب ماشي إنت جاية تكون إنت زينب كارهة وماشي دا رأيك حطيه من ضمن الفورم تمام
Learner B1: بس ما جاي تكون نسبة كبيرة قوي ومبسوطة. من أوي مستمتعة بيه عندك أرقام عندك داتا.
Learner B7: ماشي أنا أقصد لأ إنت إنت بتقول خلي الرلسكوب يبقى أصغر وناشد أقولك إنو
Learner B7: أنا أقصد أقولك إن ليه ليه أدور على بس وهو مثلا أنا بدور على تحسين عامة أنا ممكن أقارن بين ناس تانية مش عندهم ممكن مثلا أدور على ناس تانية عندها وناس عندها خبرة هي.
Learner B4: نقطة في حتة يا زلمة بس يعني عشان كده هو كل 1 حيحط رؤيته للمشكلة ورؤيته للحل
Learner B4: هو معمول يعني إحنا أحيانا نتناقش عشان نساعد بعض
Learner B4: بس كل 1 فينا حيجاوب بالمنظور اللي هو شايفه بالطريقة اللي هو شايفه فاهمة قصدي.
Learner B7: مريم.
Learner B3: أنا حابة بس ازود حاجة
Learner B3: إن هو أنا لما عملت شير لآخر مرة التاسك بتاعي هو كان تعليقه في حتة. إن أنا جبت منين فأنا حاسة برضه إن إحنا أه نركز طبعا إن إحنا كدا كدا حيبقى في من عندنا إحنا ما عندناش كل المعلومات.
Learner B3: ولكن جزء إن إحنا لازم نفهم هم عاملين دا ليه يعني مثلا مركزين قوي على نفهم الرؤية بتاعتهم جايز هم أصلا عايزين يمشوا حتة فوتور شوية
Learner B3: إن هو يبقى مش محتاج قوي حقيقيين ويقدر يعتمد على إن إحنا ندي أو فكرة من عندنا مية في المية حاسة يعني برضه ممكن نسألهم أكتر.
Learner B7: تمام.
Learner B1: الكلام اللي إنت قلتيه صح عادي يعني إنت ممكن تجيبيه على فكرة في مثلا أو كومبريتر ما استخدمتش ال إي وال فيد بتاعها كان حلو وده تمام ماشي ممكن تجيبي بلات فورم استخدمت إي آي وحاولت تنجح بس ما نجحتش عن
Learner B1: فهماني.
Learner B7: بالزبط ده. أنا كنت أقصده أقولها. إنه.
Learner B7: مشروع.
Learner B1: فيها. عادي. أنت حرة إنت حرة أهم حاجة بس تبقي عارفة يعني إيه مخك أو أو تفكيرك واصل اللي هو الحتة دي بدوري لغاية لما ال فورم يجي تمام لغاية دلوقتي إحنا ماشيين عادي
Learner B1: أنت دورت في حتة إيه الفيد باك مس
Learner B1: مش بقى اللي مش مش إيه اللي بيقدم كورسات والله لو حد بيقدم كورسات ومثلا الكورسات دي بيكون فيها مثلا في نص الكورس
Learner B1: عن طريق إيه إحنا لنا في الجزء ده بس
Learner B1: إن في يصحح أو بيدي فيدباك لل التي تسكن.
Learner B7: تمام.
Learner B1: ب.
Learner B7: ومضادات غذائية.
Learner B1: ما بقولك ده فيها نفس حتة الواقي الناس راحت.
Learner B7: أيوة حياخد وقت شوية شنو نطلع بحاجة محترمة يعني أعتقد حاجات دي عند الناس اللي بتشتغل بجد بتاخد شهور.
Learner B1: التخبط.
Learner B3: ما هو إنتو عندكو مشكلة لو مثلا سألتوا يبقى الرتو يوم الحد بدل الخميس.
Learner B7: هو أصلا يوم حد في بلانينغ تاني ولا فرنسي.
Learner B3: آخر أسبوع فهل حد ممكن يبقى عنده مشكلة.
Learner B7: ، ماشي.
Learner B1: ما.
Learner B3: هل حد عنده مشكلة لو سألته لو ممكن يبقى راتري يوم الحد بدل الخميس.
Learner B1: المسلمون التلقائي يعني.
Learner B1: يعني بتحصل تلقائي.
Learner B3: بس أنا بالنسبة لي بصراحة حد أحسن لأن بشتغل على الجمعة والسبت كان يحسن أكثر
Learner B3: بس حبيت أسألك الأول يعني مش عارفة هي.
Learner B7: أي تغيير هم بيسألونا إحنا الأول بس دايما أتوقع تغيير في المعاد يعني أظن بيدخل معانا ناس وأظن حيرجعولهم هم كمان ممكن نسأل ممكن أنا تجرب تكلمهم.
Learner B3: أنا ممكن أسأله عادي بس يعني إنتو تمام صح.
Learner B7: أيوا عادي على فكرة إن ندى هي ستروم ماستر وكدا. فهنا بتحدد وكدا بس مش.
Learner B3: طيب إيه تاني.
Learner B1: هو كده في حد تاني في التوست مش عارف هيعمل دلوقتي أو مش عارف هيعمل عشان يخلص التوست المطلوبة منه.
Learner B3: تمام بس حتتي كلها في نحنا نسأل يوزر بس.
Learner B1: ما أنا بقولك لو نسيت على إن إحنا نسأل يوزر تقدري تسألينا دلوقتي. أهو لو كلامه مين يعني إحنا.
Learner B3: مش مجمعة أسئلة.
Learner B1: المعادي خالص ممكن تبعتلي الأسئلة في.
Learner B3: روس أوكي.
Learner B1: حد تاني في التوست مش عارف لاين بكرة.
Learner B3: الدنيا. تمام يا زينب أحسن دلوقتي.
Learner B1: زينب.
Learner B7: تمام.
Learner B1: عارفة.
Learner B7: أيوا طريفة.
Learner B1: نعم.
Learner B7: أنا أتصرف عادي في التاست يعني عادي هو يعتبر حاجات.
Learner B1: مفروض تتعمله.
Learner B7: لكن الفكرة بس إن أنا أفكر كمشكلة بقى إننا أكون حاسة إن أنا إشتغلت لا دي حاجة طبعا محتاجة أيام تانية خالص محتاجة.
Learner B3: ممتاكي عامة. يا زينب أفكار أو كده على موضوع الفيد باك ممكن
Learner B3: لو حبيتي مكتبي تقوليلي أبعتلك برضه اللي أنا كنت عاملاها يعني.
Learner B7: مريم وشكرا يا مريم.
Learner B3: مع فريق إي.
Learner B1: ياسر.
Learner B1: تمام.
Learner B3: تماما
Learner B3: والباقي تمام.
Learner B1: تمام
Learner B1: أنا تمام.
Learner B4: أنا معك. معلش حاجة تشتغلش.
Learner B1: من.
Learner B4: في اي حد عنده اي حاجة واقفة.
Learner B1: تبقى تمام انا عملته اللي هو صفحة واحدة يعتبر كده. وبعده عملت اليسر ستوري في
Learner B1: وورد خدامة عملتها على تريلو بعد كده عملت ال البرتو طيب إيه على شلون في حاجة ثانية مطلوبة.
Learner B7: لكن.
Learner B4: تيكنيكال تيكنيكالتي عادي.
Learner B1: والبيك وحاجة زي كده.
Learner B4: بالضبط بالضبط هيطلعلك مسجلا أي حاجة حيطلعلك دور.
Learner B1: 200.
Learner B7: جماعة يعني السؤال ممكن يكون حاجة يعني شخصية شوية.
Learner B1: في.
Learner B7: أقصد بالنسبة للشخص كل 1 يعني
Learner B7: هلأ ما بتحسوا إن إنتو هلأ حسأل لسه أصلا؟ يعني.
Learner B1: أم.
Learner B7: هل بتحس إن إنتو لما تخلصوا التاسكن دي حاجة تقدروا انتو تنفذوها عالواقع.
Learner B4: بنسبة 70 في المية ليه علشان. أنا في الأول وفي الآخر دي كلها مش عندي جديد على هالكلام ده
Learner B4: فتقدري تقولي دي أحلام وردية أكثر أو.
Learner B7: من.
Learner B4: تكون قوي لإنك إنت ما عندكش داتا وانتي مش عارفة ال تولز اللي عندك ومش عارفة بتاعة الزاي ورا الكواسي بتاعة عندك السيلفرز فإنت عندك يعني كثير قوي
Learner B4: محتاجة تشوفيها عشان تعرفي سكان اللي أنا حقوله ده أبليكيبول ولا لأ يعني ممكن
Learner B4: مثلا حتلاقي عندك شركات مثلا سوفتوير كتير
Learner B4: بتقدر تربط مع أي منصة تانية يعني مثلا شركة أوضة عرفاها ولا لأ عارفة أوضه.
Learner B7: أيوة.
Learner B4: هل تقدر تربط مع أي
Learner B4: عندك شركات تانية تقولك لا والله أنا ما بقدرش أربط مع أي سيستم مع إن الفكرة كلها في آي عندي أوبن إي بي آي فقدر أربط مع أي حد قلت له لا والله أنا مش أوبن إي بي آي ومقدرش أفتحه ليه عشان عندي بطريقة معينة وما إلى ذلك فصعب عندي وهكذا تباع
Learner B4: فا بتشوفي تيوريتيكال أقدر أطبقها بيزنس اقدر اطبقها
Learner B4: الكابست دي عندي مش عارفة
Learner B4: فعشان كده كل حاجة قبل انك انت تغيريها عشان كدا
Learner B4: من الأول بدأ على فكرة ببساطة يعني ببساطة شديدة
Learner B4: المرونة والتغييرات السريعة وإن إنت تكون عندك مرونة إنك تستجيب للتغيرات السريعة دي ويسك اليوم الأخضر.
Learner B1: هو ما حتى لو في داتا الموضوع برضه يعني
Learner B4: كثيرة جدا إنت عندك ممكن تبقي ماشية ويقولك واللهبس عايزين أشتغلها 6 شهور
Learner B4: خلاص كده انت بازت مني كدا.
Learner B7: طيب بتحس إن إنتو تقدروا كل الفايز اللي انتو عملتوها تجمعوها وتقعدوا قدام الشركة وتعملوا بريزنتيشن بتحس انتوا تكونوا بتقولوا كلام مرتبط ببعض وجميل وكده.
Learner B1: لو إنت منظمة الأول تفكيري ما أعرفش؟
Learner B3: أنا أتفق عشان أنا مثلا بحاول أربطها بالتسك اللي فاتت يعني مثلا أي حاجة أقولها بحاول أحط معاها الرايس كور وكده
Learner B3: اكيد في اصلا عاملة كونيكتيف بحاول أعمل كده يعني.
Learner B4: نفس القصة.
Learner B3: إن شاء الله.
Learner B4: انا بصدمت جدا.
Learner B3: إن شاء الله بتحبيهم.
Learner B4: معينة. وكل فيت ريليتيد بصب بيجي ثانية أو سيكشنز تانية.
Learner B3: لازم نقعد نشاهد أفكارنا على حياتي كلها بجد.
Learner B1: وبرضه فكرة مش مش شرط الشركة مش عايزة تسمع كل اللي عملتيه
Learner B1: يعني انت شطارة إنك تقولي كلمتين وخلاص الشركة يعني اللي قدامك عايز أعرف إيه يعني ما كنت.
Learner B7: هم عايزين يعرفوا الحاجات اللي احنا ما عملنا.
Learner B1: لأ يعني مثلا أنا بكلمك في الواقع يعني يمكن لما تقولي كل كلمة لقيتيها في حد بيقولوا لأ
Learner B1: هو والله إنتو عندكو 1 2 3 مش شرط أنك تقولي يعني كل كلمة ما فيش حد بيعمل كده
Learner B1: المهم لسه ما جبت.
Learner B3: أتفق بجد حسن أهم حاجتين هو أول حاجة هيقيسوا طريقة تفكيرك أهم من أي حاجة أوكي حاسة برضه مهمة العائد وأنت مبنية على إيه
Learner B3: دي أكتر حاجتين حيركزوا فيها قوي يعني
Learner B3: بس إحنا ممكن نسأله المرة الجاية فعلا على لأن نبدأ بقى من دلوقتي أنا تقريبا أسبوعين ولا حاجة علي.
Learner B7: أيوة.
Learner B4: هي الأولى.
Learner B3: طيب ندى أنا كنت بسأل ندى انتي سمعانا صح.
Learner B4: ، سامعك معاكي.
Learner B3: أنا كنت بسأل إن أنا كنت مش عارفة بس أنا برضه ما عنديش مشكلة إن أنا أبعت إن إحنا.
Learner B4: من.
Learner B3: دون حد مع بلانينغ.
Learner B4: هو ببساطة هيقول لك عندما كلكم تتفقوا فهل احنا كلنا متفقين.
Learner B7: أيوا. أنا متفقة. عندي بس أعتقد هم كمان في ناس بتدخل معانا يعني
Learner B7: فأتوقع هم كمان أكون متوقف عليهم قبل كده كنا منغير ستاندرد ميتينغز العادية.
Learner B4: طيب لأ بغض النظر يعني إحنا مو تيم عندنا يعني ياب تمام روان تمام يبقى يوم الحد بس سؤال يا مريم إنت عايزة يكون الرتر بس ولا قصدك الريتر وال ديد لاين.
Learner B3: لا، لا، ال ديد لاين. أنا مش فارقة معايا عادي ممكن أسلمه النهاردة هو أكيد يستحسن لو في على فكرة كانت حصلت قبل كده
Learner B3: بس كان في لخبطة يعني اتقال في إكستنشن النهارده، فما فهمتش
Learner B1: ما ممكن على الأحوال ساعات بيقول إن ريترو مش ريتر مش هينفع يتغير بش مهندسين مش فاضين.
Learner B3: ما هو كده في يوم لحد نفس الساعة.
Learner B1: خلاص انت ممكن تقولي النقطة دي أو تدخلي بيها يعني المهندس على طول ما 1,000.
Learner B3: ابعتله برايفات يعني لو ندا هي اللي بتبعتله حبة انتي تبعتيله براحتك يعني.
Learner B4: مشكلة يبقى مع الحد مع بلانك.
Learner B3: إمم أيوه.
Learner B4: أوكي ماشي خلاص خليني أبعتها على طول ثواني ياسر تمام عدل تمام.
Learner B1: تمام.
Learner B4: ياسر وروان.
Learner B5: ، تمام ماشي.
Learner B4: تمام ياسر.
Learner B4: انت تمام. يبقى مع الحد مع بلانينغ
Learner B4: زينب تمام ياسر. عادل تمام ياسر مش سمعنا تقريبا كوسة ماشي أغلبية احمد واقول لكم على طول.
Learner B3: أوكي.
Learner B4: أي حاجة أي حاجة يبعتلي لو اقدر اساعدها أساعدك انتي.
Learner B3: خلاص مع السلامة.
Learner B4: أوكي يا شباب أيوه سنة.